jacques commence sa journée à 6h30 à
l'entrepôt des restos du coeur aux
clayes-sous-bois depuis douze ans il a
les mêmes rituels préparer les commandes
les emballer et les charger mais depuis
quelques temps le manque d'effectifs se
fait de plus en plus ressentir
les années passent si vous voulez hier
25 kg c'était rigolo
aujourd'hui 25 kg ont la rive touche
dans les 70 ans passés bon 25 kg
deviennent très très lourd et on demande
à
à chacun bon attention fait attention on
fait attention à sif attention à ça et
on essaie d'aller de l'avant mais il est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui s'il nous manque une
personne
c'est un problème dans les yvelines 1200
bénévoles travaillent chaque jour dans
les 26 centres pour distribuer les
denrées alimentaires élu depuis
septembre le nouveau président
s'inquiète du peu d'intérêt que porte la
jeunesse pour l'association
on a de moins en moins de candidatures
hélas on a quand même un certain nombre
de bénévoles qui nous quitte pour des
raisons tout à fait normal c'est que
l'on ait abandonné de temps qu'ils
aspirent à voir un petit peu à peu plus
de tranquillité
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le
problème dont souffrent avant tout les
restos du coeur et le réseau associatif
c'est un manque de bénévoles un appel à
l'aide de l'association pour combler le
manque d'effectifs
malgré le besoin de bénévoles les
livraisons arriveront à temps à trappes
saint pierre bois d'arcy et tous les
autres centres des restos du coeur dans
les yvelines